check check check
one two
oh caught you guys off guard didn't I
caught you guys off guard if you were
expecting
a countdown no no no no no no no
countdown tonight
we're going live on the dot right at 9
00 PM eastern time people love the
internet welcome to Retro records are
live for the week
of April 25th 2023. coming up
on tonight's show Diablo 4 is getting
another open Beta PlayStation has
acquired another Studio Dead Island 2 is
off to a fast sale start more Horizons
on the way and if you're looking forward
to Star Wars Jedi Survivor spoilers are
officially out beware plus our topic of
the week for tonight Harry Potter
Quidditch Champions the recently
announced Standalone multiplayer title
featuring the iconic Wizarding World
sport we'll also be taking a look at the
new games coming out this week and talk
about what I've been playing lately but
first
it's time to say hello to you guys the
chat welcome in everybody Welcome in
thank you all so much for being here uh
for those of you who don't know
we stream live here at youtube.com
retroacting tour used to do it every
Tuesday around 8 30 or so Eastern Time
now we're bumping it up to around 9pm
eastern time Tuesday evenings my son had
baseball practice tonight
and I just knew I knew we weren't going
to be able to make it in time
so here we are though we made it welcome
in welcome in
hope everybody is doing well let's see
we got Harry Potter ladies and gentlemen
Harry Potter in the chat tonight the
very first person that I saw in the chat
house reckon to remember Alicia is here
with us Nico the real life Chief warlock
in the house Jake AKA our buddy hi one
two three hi
he asked one time how do I remember the
name I I don't know dude I I honestly
don't know I have no idea
let's see Mia in the house as well we
got Ken Harry Potter with the Super Chat
as well Harry thank you so much for the
Super Chat my friend very much
appreciate it I'm doing well doing well
good to see you thank you for being here
and hanging out oh man here's a name in
Andres
I cannot pronounce my apologies
kucharski am I close there at least on
the last name welcome in thank you for
being here we've got Darren in the house
as well JP raven fire Ryan De La Cruz
Ryan how's it going good to see you good
to see you Mia in the house as well your
West Coast audience likes this time
right I know this is a little bit better
we're always I mean no matter when we
stream no matter when we go live it's
always affecting somebody can't make it
whether it's our
audience overseas whether it's our West
Coast
always somebody who can't make it but
that's why you know I gotta keep
everybody guessing keep you all on your
toes you never know when we may be live
so
uh thank you guys so much for being here
oh also Hanson edits in the house as
well thoughts on the HP show oh yeah I
wanted to I wanted to make a
I want to make a thing where you guys
can submit so
as you can see there from the intro
trying something a little bit different
here with the show obviously with
Hogwarts Legacy being out we wanted to
keep doing the live streams but now we
can't just focus on that every time I'm
also thinking about turning this into a
podcast as well so just to give you guys
since this is our first time doing this
just to give you all kind of a little
overview of what I'm thinking here we'll
always have the intro and I think I'm
going to start live just just right into
it like that instead of having the
countdown because whenever people see a
VOD on YouTube whenever they go back and
try to watch something and you have this
weird annoying countdown there
it's like come on I'm not gonna sit here
for 10 minutes and you know some people
maybe they'll skip ahead but a lot of
people are just going to be like eh I'm
clicking out of this and they're gone
so I'm just going to start like that
we're just going to start right in right
from the beginning we'll put time stamps
later so people want to jump around any
section they can so we'll have that
intro we'll have this little chat
interaction moment here then I've got
segments I've got segments planned for
you guys tonight uh Harry Potter with
another Super Chat thank you so much my
friend the 99 cent Super Chat appreciate
that my friend so yeah we'll have uh the
intro the chat greetings then what I'm
calling the weekly recap so those
stories that you heard me kind of hint
at at the beginning
we'll just go over those briefly so I'll
cover those five stories probably read
some uh news articles on each one of
those
that'll be you know maybe a 15 minute
segment or so not too much interaction
just keeping you guys up to date with
everything that's going on then we'll
talk about new releases so everything
that's came out what I've been playing
I'll be checking the chat see what you
guys have been playing and then where
we'll have the bulk of our discussion is
the topic of the week
and so for this week our topic of the
week is going to be Harry Potter
Quidditch Champions with some of you out
there right now some of you out there
watching may very well have played this
you may you may very well be playing it
right now because it is officially
they have oh what are they calling it
they're not calling it a beta play test
they're calling it play test so they
have these play tests open and they've
said more invites excuse me are going to
be going out but we don't know when we
don't know how many we we don't know a
lot really
so it's almost a good thing that I'm not
I mean in some ways it is I really want
to be playing to be honest with you but
in some ways it is a good thing because
it gives me a little bit more freedom to
talk about it because it seems like
those that are playing are under an NDA
so they can't really talk much about it
at all
so we'll have our topic of the week and
then we'll have a section for viewer
questions so there is a way on YouTube
that you guys can submit questions so
let me actually go ahead and get that
set up right now
to where
uh you guys can just submit those in
because I saw somebody was already
asking about the possibilities of like
uh asking my thoughts on the TV show
which that is like that is a perfect
example that's like a great great
example of a question right there as I
hear myself a double right there okay so
let's do start a q a
uh so what do we what do we want to call
this segment we'll call it
we'll call it viewer questions submit
your viewer questions
for tonight's stream here
all right start q a
so then we'll have the Q a and then I
was trying to get something cool for the
wrap up
because like a like a shout out or
so what I thought what I came up with is
shouting out like the top comment of the
week
so maybe finding one of my favorite
comments from the YouTube channel
throughout the week and highlighting
that person from the community and also
highlighting their comment just to
encourage more more positive comments
which you guys watch in the live right
now I don't need to tell you this
because you already post the positive
comments but man you get some weird
comments on YouTube you really do some
really strange comments so that's kind
of the layout that's what I'm planning
for the show and I want to stick with it
you know I we tried this a little bit
how are you few weeks ago and we just
sort of watched some trailers but it
didn't really have a lot of structure to
it tonight we're changing it up change
it up we're gonna try to stick with it
yo do we have some gifted memberships
going out what is happening right now
uh rohita
oh man I might be pronouncing that
incorrectly too with five gifted Subs
and look at that Mrs retro raconteur got
one of those gifted Subs that is a legit
account ladies and gentlemen that is
indeed a legit account Mrs retro
racketour Draco and then Harry Potter
also Craig and let's see who else
kucharski how are you all of you just
got gifted membership so uh rohits thank
you so much for the gifteds appreciate
that my friend uh guys whenever you have
a gifted membership here on YouTube how
are you get a special Discord roll and
you also have access to our emotes there
in the chat great way to support the
stream support the channel so appreciate
that my friend welcome to Griffin all
right so I think we're ready to uh let's
go ahead and shift into our first
segment which is going to be the weekly
recap
how are you welcome to Gryffindor
there you go look look see see we got
little uh we got slides here ready to go
so this is where we're gonna start
each week we'll start with something
like this and then we'll shift over into
our weekly recap so there you can see
those are the five big stories that we
have
and I want to start right there at the
top the Diablo 4. I know some of you
guys out there in our community are
interested in this because I've seen
some of you playing it so this article
comes to us from Game Informer dated
April 20th Diablo 4 gets another open
Beta weekend next month
Diablo 4 may have gone gold but blizzard
wants to ensure the servers are durable
one more time before launch thus it's
opening the gates of sanctuary to
players one more time in a third open
Beta next month this next test weekend
dubbed server slam Weekend begins May
12th at 12 p.m Pacific and ends May 14th
at the same time as the name suggests
blizzard is running this beta to stress
test the servers to make sure they're as
sturdy as possible come June
uh let's see this slice of the game is
similar to the March betas in terms of
content but it will include updates and
Bug fixes garnered from feedback to the
previous betas
server slam will be a clean slate as
progression from the previous betas does
not carry over
Additionally the beta Sports couch Co-op
you don't see a lot of that these days
you know uh cross play and cross
progression and then at the end here
Diablo 4 Launches on June 6 for
Playstation Xbox and PC it's also game
informers cover story for this month
so there you go that is our first story
there all about Diablo 4 the open Beta
if you guys missed that you will have
one more chance before the game comes
out on June 6th which we still have I
mean that's still a little bit of time
before uh but yeah May 12th so you got
some time before that beta as well
all right and Story number two
of the night
PlayStation acquiring another Studio
firewalk Studios I don't think this
one's gonna be submitted to like uh
all those FCC hearings like what's going
on with Xbox and Activision for you know
I think for obvious reasons but uh
Playstation acquires this comes to us
from again Game Informer news
PlayStation acquires firewalk Studios
team developing a triple a multiplayer
game so we've known about this for a
while that Sony has several different
free to play games in the works now it
doesn't say if this one's free to play
or not but they have clearly saw what's
been going on with all the success
lately of free to play games uh by the
way Darren with the Super Chat thank you
so much my friend appreciate that
appreciate the super chats guys thank
you all for the support so uh here's the
story on that when the company announced
this on a new Playstation blog noting
that it's been in a publishing
partnership with firewalk Studios and
probably monsters since 2021 and that
it's now happy to expand that
relationship by bringing the studio
under the PlayStation umbrella the
studio has been working on its first
original AAA multiplayer game for
Playstation and it sounds like
development on that will continue
companies did not mention a price for
the acquisition here's what firewalk
Studios had Tony Sue and game director
Ryan Ellis have to say about the
acquisition
oh wow this is like a this is like a
really they have like this really
lengthy quote here we'll be part of it
here we'll be part of it every once in a
while you get to have an adventure over
five years ago we jumped at the chance
to set up a new studio and build a new
IP from the ground up recalling our own
favorite times with games we founded
firewalk studios around the idea of
delivering memorable moments those
amazing had to be there time share with
other people our goal is to deliver
those shared moments of joy to players
around the world
building a new studio at scale has been
an incredibly exhilarating and
relentlessly daunting task
fortunately we've been supported by
great Partners throughout probably
monsters helped Turbo Charge Us in
setting up the studio and Sony has been
supporting our project and our Creative
Vision from the beginning
today we're taking the next natural step
and joining PlayStation Studios we've
worked closely with Herman and the very
talented team at PlayStation for years
helping to make our new game even better
to join PlayStation Studios is to
formally become part of a family that
has produced many of the most storied
games of our age and we are honored
uh let's see then it goes on to say here
PlayStation's acquisition of firewalk
Studios yeah this is what we were
alluding to at the beginning
it comes at an interesting moment for
the company as it continues to publicly
push back and fight against Microsoft's
ongoing efforts to have its Act was just
acquisition of Activision it's hard to
say their acquisition of Activision
Activision Blizzard that is approved by
governmental bodies around the world are
you excited for a triple a multiplayer
game from a PlayStation first party
Studio let us know in the comments below
so that's Story number two number three
on our list Dead Island 2
off to a fantastic start in terms of
sales uh this one comes to us from IGN
deep silver and
Dan Buster is that how you say that damn
Buster Studios announced that Dead
Island 2 has sold over 1 million copies
within the first three days of release
quote Dead Island 2 has won fans from
around the world with countless players
snapping up a copy of the drop dead
gorgeous game that was not me that was
that was the quote I promised that was a
quote in the first 72 hours Deep Silver
said in a press release furthermore
in-game stats will reveal detailing how
many players did certain actions thus
far players have slayed 1.1 billion
zombies hacked off 756 million zombie
Limbs and slice 45 million zombies in
half
there you go I've heard there were some
problems with Dead Island on YouTube for
people who are trying to cover this game
on YouTube because of all the gore I
think a lot of these videos are getting
uh demonetized so you can't monetize
them unless you I guess blur a lot of
stuff out so kind of tricky kind of
tricky when it comes to covering games
like that the latter number is also over
twice the population of the game setting
in Los Angeles if you're still hankering
for some more Dead Island too a UK
insurance company is offering
like what what what is this is offering
a Dead Island 2 life insurance policy
I I I think they're trying to make jokes
here
I think that's intended to be a joke
uh Dead Island 2 is available now on PC
PlayStation 4 PlayStation 5 Xbox One and
Xbox series X and S I honestly like I
have to click this link now I have to
click this link about I mean what what
is this UK insurance company offers Dead
Island 2 themed
life insurance package
as reported by VGC the dead happy life
insurance company which offers a variety
of different life insurance packages
with some quirkier than others is
offering the Dead Island 2 package what
oh my goodness I I I literally thought
this was a joke apparently not
apparently not
apparently it is indeed legit all right
and our fourth news story of the Night
Gorilla Games casually drops Horizon 3
reference
fans of Gorilla Games Horizon universe
as well as its ears wait I thought it
said irresistible
irrepressible hero a Loy will be pleased
to hear that we can expect much more
from the robot filled dystopia following
comments from the studio that casually
reference at least one more title in the
visually stunning Adventure series the
comments came following a shake-up of
gorilla staff which sees Studio director
and executive producer Angie Smith's
lead the developer to take up a new role
as PlayStation Studios head of
development strategy
absence producer director Joel eschler
and general manager hella Schmidt will
receive promotion within studio ranks
while current Studio director Jan Bart
Van Beek will retain their role at
gorilla overseeing all current and
future projects okay so the actual quote
here
uh it was when they were discussing
smency's departure so here here's the
quote gorilla notes that it quote has
full confidence in our new leadership as
they steer gorilla towards a brighter
future expanding the world of horizon
with eloy's next adventure and our
exciting online project close quote so
not a huge surprise there Horizon zero
Dawn Horizon forbidden West uh and then
what's the burning Shores I think is the
name of the DLC which just came out I
still haven't played forbidden West
played Horizon zero Dawn enjoyed it want
to play the sequel but my backlog is
just you know it's it's ridiculously
long at this point
but I think I'll get to it at some point
I do I enjoyed the first one I didn't
like love it I didn't think it was the
most amazing game ever but I mean
Dinosaur Mix come on so it's really no
surprise I don't think it's a surprise
anyway that there are in fact more games
coming uh that that story by the way
came to us from Destructoid and then
last but not least this is a big one for
our audience here I feel like a lot of
you guys are into Star Wars so no to be
clear no spoilers here tonight on this
uh we're just talking about the warning
of spoilers is what we're going to be
talking about so EA has actually tweeted
out uh no spoilers we're Beyond excited
for everyone to experience Star Wars
Jedi Survivor this week we ask that you
please be mindful of others and avoid
posting or sharing spoilers and remember
BD is watching so that's the Tweet they
put out but apparently spoilers are
already making their way online people
do have the game it's not out until
Friday I think is the release day
so while the Twitter oh wait so wait
hold on hold on hold on let's back up
here let's back up I'm gonna read this
full article this one is from
PlayStation lifestyle publisher EA has
hit out at those posting Star Wars Jedi
Survivor spoilers after the game was
leaked yesterday while the Twitter
account that originally leaked aspects
of the game has since been removed the
story and Game feature spoiler still
persist across different parts of the
internet we will not be revealing those
spoilers here not only has EA requested
players to quote be mindful of others
and avoid posting or sharing spoilers
ahead of the release of Star Wars Jedi
Survivor on April 28th but developers
from respawn have also been posting
their own concerns senior writer Pete
Stewart pointed out that quote for us
it's really disheartening to see
spoilers as well close quote while EA's
Global director of integrated comms for
Shooters and Star Wars Andy McNamara
asked players to quote please be
respectful of the experience for others
close quote the spoilers can still be
seen across the internet on places like
Twitter and Reddit so be careful with
your browsing ahead of the start of
preloading tonight at 9 PM Pacific time
the PS5 file size has been reported as
over 140 gigabytes and even those with a
disk copy will need to download some
aspects of the game
all right so that is it for our weekly
recap man that that's so unfortunate
about the spoilers it really is because
I I just finished playing Star Wars uh
Jedi fall in order if you guys didn't
see this we streamed it over on Twitch
we also posted our full Let's Plays over
on our let's play Channel retro records
or let's plays and I'm really enjoying
that game and there are some major I'm
not even gonna say it here there are
some major story elements in that game
that somehow I I went
a few things I knew but there was a lot
of stuff I didn't know and man it just
like seeing seeing the big reveal at the
end of the first game like imagine
something like of that magnitude being
spoiled for spoiled for people
very unfortunate very unfortunate
all right so for some reason my let's
see
I can't see my chat for some reason my
chat is now disappeared hold on let me
pull it up
laughs
guys if you do have any questions to
submit you can use uh we have a little
link to do that all you have to do is
look in the chat and we'll answer those
at the end
there we go okay now I can see it no
worries Jason no worries Craig no
worries
you're a wizard is never late Jason
that's what I always like to say
that's what I always like to say my
friend
all right so that concludes our weekly
recap all right new releases guys for
the upcoming week
this is courtesy of Metacritic here this
is the week of April 24th so we have
after image an action adventure
releasing on PS5 wow basically
everything uh PS5 Xbox series s and X
PS4 Xbox One PC Nintendo switch on April
25th stranded alien Dawn
same consoles also releasing on the 25th
Trinity trigger also releasing on the
25th that one is on PS5 PS4 PC and the
Nintendo switch we have Bramble the
Mountain King releasing on April 27th on
again pretty much everything PS5 PS4 PC
Xbox series X and S
Xbox One and the Nintendo switch then we
have I was trying to think how is this
pronounced anybody in the chat know live
Alive live a live live alive
that is an RPG strategy releasing on
April 27th for PS5 PS4 and PC then we
have a monster hunter expansion that has
uh Monster Hunter rise Sun Break on
April 28th that's going to land on PS5
Xbox series X and S PS4 and Xbox One and
then the big one of course Star Wars
Jedi Survivor April 28th next gen only
so that one is only hitting on PS5 Xbox
series X and S I'm just not gonna say s
every time
people know right I mean that's like
generally understood if you have an Xbox
series X when you hear
the Xbox series X you just know it's
also on the S
it's when Microsoft chose that naming
scheme I mean I get why they did it but
I can also see how it could be confusing
in some instances so those are the
releases this week can't say that I know
much about any of those with the
exception of Star Wars Jedi Survivor
Xbox series yeah that's a good way Craig
princess loving the slides nice thank
you yeah I I thought it would be helpful
visually to as we kind of go through
these different segments and especially
as people are going back through and
catching the live
it'll help it uh help people follow
along I hope so that's what's Landing
this week guys and then
it's time for a little uh hear from you
guys what have you been playing lately
we already kind of alluded to it with me
what I've been playing lately so let's
see my kids I've said this many times
they're they're so into fortnite I have
an eight-year-old and a four-year-old
both of them actually have birthdays
coming up but they are they are so in
love with fortnite I mean it just just
every day like they they talk we're
actually really having to watch and
monitor how much
how much time they're on there and limit
it each day because they are they are so
into it so every now and then about once
I'd say about once or twice a week I'll
hop in there and play some with them
which guys I I kid you not man we're
pretty close to the point where my
eight-year-old is better than me at
Fortnight I don't think we're there yet
I don't think we're there yet but we are
getting
dangerously dangerously close which is
insane like I can't believe I'm saying
that
I really can't believe I'm saying that
Jason you've been stubbing your toe
Ken's been playing Assassin's Creed
Odyssey nice Mia been playing Witcher 3
since the Next Gen update a sign Focus
build Mia I heard they changed that it
feels a little more like the way the
spell casting Works in Hogwarts Legacy
I've heard that and I and I I hopped in
I did a video on it and just captured
some footage for the game but very very
briefly and I tested it out a little bit
um but that is a game man I I love that
game so much but it was the combat I can
I never found the combat super engaging
and every now and then I'll be like I'm
gonna go back I'm gonna try it again and
see if it feels different because if
that game like if it if it had the
combat of a Souls game or even the
combat of something like
Star Wars we were just talking about
Fallen order
I love that so much I mean it would
probably be one of my favorite games
ever
Harry Potter with another Super Chat
Harry Potter man thank you for all the
love tonight uh and in that Super Chat
Harry says I've been playing Red Dead 2
oh my gosh Harry don't get mad at me
please don't get mad at me but that one
is on my it's in my backlog
it is in my very lengthy backlog
and I've started it I don't know how far
through it I am I'm definitely I'm not
even halfway because it's a really long
game but
I don't know I'm I'm through like the
first
I'd say probably 10 hours of the game
same thing with Ghost of tsushima I'm a
little bit more further into that one
and I know I would love both of those
games I know I would and I'm those are
two that I absolutely like I know I have
to get to them eventually I have to
so those are pretty close on on my like
the top of my backlog list they're in
like that top five games I need to get
to
so in addition to fortnite with my kids
though what I've been playing my
youngest loves Mario party so we've been
playing some Mario party as well and
then I just finished if you guys follow
along our our twitch streams I just
finished Star Wars Jedi Fallen order
and honestly like finishing it so close
to Survivor I thought I was going to
finish it and then be like ah I need a
break I'm not ready to jump right back
in
but I the ending man the ending of that
game
they really did a good job with uh
ending it on a high note man it really
ended in a good spot and it kind of just
has me itching for the next one to be
honest so
Mr seven digit mostly Hogwarts Legacy
just got 100 percent nice A little bit
of cyberpunk dude is it finally time do
I need to go back to cyberpunk actually
I can't say go back because I've never
played it do I need to finally add it
here's a fun story about cyberpunk man I
was so close like the week
I think it was the week of launch of the
game
I was like hovering on the pre-order
button hovering on it and I was like
yeah I know CD project red I feel like
it's going to be a pretty solid game
but what held me back is I just had so
many other things that I was playing at
the time so many other things that I was
working on and I didn't do it it's like
nah okay I'm not gonna pre-order it I'll
wait I can wait for a sale easily
what did I dodge when it launched there
it's actually in a really good spot a
really good spot Nico I feel like a
weirdo couldn't get into Horizons seems
like people love it I mean I feel like I
enjoyed it but I still feel like I'm
kind of in that almost in that camp too
of because it seems like there's a lot
of people who really really love it who
really love it I think the biggest
things for me were I mean Dynamics come
on come on dynamex alone and then bow
and arrow give me a bow and arrow that
that might be my favorite weapon in
video games is a bow and arrow
I love it so much man so those aspects I
feel like they nail but yeah everything
else in Horizon I'm just gonna like oh
yeah okay it's solid it's solid
which for me like Star Wars fall in
order here's my thoughts on it
I really enjoyed the game
and this is why when I was a kid and
even even growing up I was like man all
these people who say they don't want or
they don't like review scores I can't I
don't see why anybody would ever say
that that's ridiculous and now the older
I get the more I understand like I I
really do understand it because I
wouldn't want to put a score on Star
Wars because to me
this is it is like such a good example
of a game that's that's a really good
game but not a great game not a great
game and and I don't mean that as like
an insult like I'm I'm happy I played it
I had a great time playing it almost
like when people talk about movies and
they say oh that's a popcorn flick
it's like I don't need I don't need
every movie or every game that I play to
completely change my life right I don't
need to be saying this is this is the
greatest thing I've ever experienced you
know just like oh man that was that was
a fun 15 20 hours you know and that's
where how I feel about Fallen order I
loved so many aspects of it I like the
combat quite a bit lightsaber I mean I
haven't played every Star Wars game
certainly but it's pretty darn close to
having the best combat of a Star Wars
game I I mean I feel like it's it's got
to be up there
Dylan I see in the chat with the nine
months thank you so much Dylan Dylan is
a big Star Wars fan Dylan might might be
able to speak to uh if any other Star
Wars games really rival it I know oh
what was the one back in the day man
Jedi Jedi Knight 2 Jedi Academy I think
was the was the name of it
foreign
cyberpunk might be too adult for this
family oh trust me JP I know yeah yeah I
know all about it
I didn't say anything about covering it
on the channel I said playing it myself
big big difference
as you started Horizon and then put it
down interesting Ken you were also like
that for Horizon dove into forbidden
West right after oh you're talking about
what I was speaking to earlier how uh
with Star Wars I just wanted to jump
right back in
Jason you're trying Parasite Eve one and
two I can't I've never played those
ghosts of tsushima on PS5 is an
experience on another level yeah Craig
whenever I go back to it I think I will
because I have the PS4 disc version and
I think I'll just go ahead and pay for
the upgrade because that's one of those
games where even though I have the disc
PS4
this is really cool actually I don't
know if a lot of people even know this
you can pay
for just like an upgrade to the PS5
version and then basically my PS4 disc
it becomes like my PS5 copy so to play
it it's not like I get a digital copy to
play it I still have to put in my PS4
disk and then you probably have to you
probably have to be online for that to
work every time though I would think
right or actually no because you have
the disc I feel like once you do it it's
like that's your kind of verification
and so I think it was only like 10 20
bucks or something so whenever I finally
do get back
I'm gonna have to do that
Knights of the Old Republic yeah yeah
yeah but in terms of like lightsaber
combat though Knights of the Old
Republic what I mean it's a great game I
totally agree one of my favorite Star
Wars games ever actually
it might be my favorite Star Wars game
Knights of the Old Republic
it would come down to Rogue leader Rogue
Squadron 2 on the GameCube Knights of
the Old Republic and then the one I just
played Fallen order would definitely
come down to one of those
Jason said nice to the Old Republic
Simeon said Knights of the Old Republic
Jason oh wait Jason again Jason kidding
oh I see you left out the old the first
time all good all good
yeah but like just in terms of
lightsaber combat
I feel like Fallen orders got to be up
there which it seems like Survivor could
potentially
be even better with all the stances and
stuff that they're introducing you've
got the double blade you've got like a
he can have like a pistol now in
addition to a lightsaber you can have
the lightsaber in each hand there's all
sorts of uh opportunity for this next
one to to do even better
all right so that is what I've been
playing for the week and what you guys
have been playing now it's time to get
into our topic of the week
topic of the week and boy
is it a big one I think we haven't
talked about this on YouTube yet I went
live on Twitch the day the announcement
hit
but this is our first time
getting to talk about it here with the
YouTube audience so Harry Potter
Quidditch Champions guys it is happening
quidditch is actually happening
and some of you I'm so jealous can you
guys tell I'm a little jealous some of
you may have already played it but you
can't say anything can you you can't say
anything because there is an NDA
or I should say you've played an early
version of it uh but yeah anybody else
watching this later if you didn't know
this is official this is not a hoax
I I had to check the Tweet you guys when
the announcement first went up I had to
check the Tweet so many times
to make sure that this wasn't like I'm
checking all the the different Twitter
check marks now you know I'm like wait
okay which check mark is this is this
legit oh wow this is actually
the WB account what's crazy man is they
had to keep that so Under Wraps like how
did that not leak right
how did that not leak I guess after
Hogwarts Legacy leaked so early they
were just determined to keep
a tight lid on things and
I mean they did a great job
Lauren welcome in from New York City
late to the party hey all good all good
Draco you've been playing Harry Potter
magic awakened I know we're still
waiting for that over here in the U.S
too
dude this could be an insane year though
for Wizarding World fans think about it
think about it Hogwarts Legacy comes out
which who knows what they have up their
sleeve for DLC
and when it may hit
I mean potentially like if they've
already been working on it
like maybe as they were building the
game they set aside some things that
were like oh man this is too big of an
idea to fit into the core game
let's start kind of developing that on
the side here as as DLC
or if they're just like we haven't even
thought about DLC now I know what
they've said publicly and that it's not
in the what do they how do they word it
current plans or something
um and of course they're going to be
focused solely on
last gen which is where the focus should
be
I mean we are so close to last gen at
this point let's see is it next week no
it's not next week it is uh no it is
next week it is next Friday you guys no
spoilers by the way no spoilers for
anybody watching tonight we're not going
to spoil anything I know we have a lot
of people who like to watch tune in on
the live streams uh who haven't gotten
to play the game yet so don't worry
we're not going to be spoiling anything
but yeah you have just over about a week
and a half to go
oh my goodness that is crazy
May 5th
May 5th and I know it's been a long time
coming for you guys I'm still waiting on
for them to finally fix the collector's
edition trophy
I still have not gotten it man
I still have not gotten it Draco you
still hop in to uh fly around it's just
I know just just being in that world I
want a reason to go back I really do
I really want a reason to go back which
we still are doing our evil playthrough
as well now that we've beaten Fallen
order if that'll give us a chance to
jump back in for that but what are you
guys looking to see out of this
Quidditch game
what are you all looking to see and
actually how do you feel about it too
let me know let me know in the comments
there I want to hear how you guys feel
about it because I was actually
surprised now being that I have a
YouTube channel
I see a lot of the negativity
so I mean my general thought when I
first saw this is people are going to be
so freaking excited
so excited and I and I still feel like
that is the majority I do I really do
but there is a pretty vocal group who
seem upset that this game
that that almost like they're upset that
this was the reason it's not in Hogwarts
Legacy
and I'm just like guys Hogwarts Legacy
was a
I mean even if you do like bare minimum
like bare minimum it's a 40 hour
experience like that is a full game now
for me it was an 80-hour experience
doing everything getting all the
Collectibles that's just one playthrough
if you do more playthroughs you're gonna
get even more so I mean like I I just
don't get that argument of of saying
like
I
that it's somehow unfair or something
like it's it's a cash grab of course
guys everything everything that comes
out it's I mean it's it's to make money
like that is the point however this this
exact thing that they're doing now let's
be fair we've not seen any gameplay
haven't seen anything at all about it
but the way that they're doing this at
least is exactly what what so many of us
wanted we said you know what
I would much rather a studio
take their time build a Quidditch game
from the ground up on their own engine
you almost need an engine where you're
building the game just around quidditch
versus something like Hogwarts Legacy
where it's like added in
and I mean I feel like we have the proof
of this too and all you have to do is
look at
with a troll cup
and then look at the Quidditch that we
had in the early versions of the Harry
Potter games
I mean the only reason they were able to
put that in those games guys I've said
this many times but I'll say it again
here the only reason they were able to
include quidditch in those old games is
because you were one position
and it was the Seeker they all the other
stuff they could just have the AI around
you controlling it right
that's the only reason man
and even quidditch World Cup
didn't have you like in full control of
each position they were there were ways
you know like when you uh when you had a
bludger you would like take control of
the beater for a second
um but mostly you play the chaser
and then when it comes time to catch the
snakes the snitch you play The Seeker
for a bit so I I mean before I look at
chat and read your all's feedback I'll
say that I'm I'm totally like on board
for this I think this is the right move
uh I think I I don't feel like it should
have been included in Hogwarts Legacy
and even if it had even if it had been
included
it would not have been
something like what we're gonna get here
it would have been it would have been
almost like a mini game like like a
cross ones a side thing that you would
have been able to do uh so I I
definitely think it was the right call I
think we're gonna get a much better game
experience as a result uh but let's see
what you guys think here let's see uh
zodiac says I wouldn't mind a career
mode like in a lot of sports games 100
agree with you there zodiac totally
agree I I think
to do this right and to really increase
the replayability of it which they've
said there's a lot of questions about is
it multiplayer only
we know it's definitely multiplayer and
we know online is required but then they
also have a line in there about being
able to play solo
what I'm not clear on with that solo is
does that just mean like solo queue but
you're still playing with other people
like right now I can hop on fortnite and
I can I can solo queue but I'm still
going against other players will there
be a way for somebody who's like you
know what I don't really want any of the
multiplayer stuff
but can I still just hop in and play
Quidditch against some AI opponents pick
any position I want go through a full
quidditch season I mean similar to like
what you got with quidditch World Cup
right
that blew my mind by the way with
quidditch World Cup the fact that you
had
that core game of the Hogwarts cup but
then no they actually have the Quidditch
World Cup too where you can be so we
don't know anything like that yet we
don't know anything about if it's how
many teams are going to be included
here's kind of the basics in terms of
gameplay what we know
I'm fairly confident that we'll be able
to play every position I'm I'm fairly
confident of that a couple reasons they
mentioned it in the tweet and then also
if you're a member of their Discord they
already have separate Discord channels
set up for each position so I think that
for sure is being included as a reason
because they want people to talk
strategy based on which one you're
playing
and then we know it's multiplayer like
those are the two big things that we
know
we know that you could play any position
and we know that it's multiplayer
wouldn't mind uh okay hold on Samantha
said looking forward to it never played
a Quidditch game before Mia says I'm
scared I'll be as bad at it in the
flying challenges as I was in Hogwarts
Legacy oh man
Craig says don't like multiplayer Craig
Okay so
would you be okay with it though if
you have some options to play offline or
not offline because it sounds like it
sounds like an online connection is
required against like AI
because or do you mean they shouldn't
include multiplayer at all because for a
game like this there's no way it would
have any chance of success if they had
no multiplayer
there's just there's just no way it
would have any chance of success
it has absolutely has to have
multiplayer for any chance of success
and and Longevity you know
Mr seven digit don't feel like playing
anything else after Hogwarts it left the
void right
it definitely did that's why I'm just
like come on DLC announcement I'm
waiting for it Draco don't know if I'll
play the Quidditch game plan to hit
Harry Potter magic awaken hard I love
dueling so much yeah I mean I will say
like I was never one of those people
banging the table like I absolutely have
to have quidditch in Hogwarts Legacy
honestly because it just like I enjoy
sports games but I would I would take
like the action RPG any day of the week
however I mean I will say this has got I
think this has a lot of potential for
the people who are fans of quidditch and
for the people who have been saying like
oh I want to play Quidditch this whole
time
life is a cash crap right Jason money I
mean it's just it's necessary
it is necessary
exactly Dylan like if if they did it in
Hogwarts Legacy it I feel like it would
have only been a half a half done
version and not that's not an insult to
Avalanche just because of the sheer
capacity that it would take
to make a quality Quidditch game quality
quitter supplies to make a quality
Quidditch game right and I mean again I
go back to quidditch World Cup and
comparing quidditch to those other games
I mean all you have to do is look at the
the vast vast difference in terms of the
quality of the gameplay
in how it worked with those games and I
think you have the perfect example there
princess says I think quidditch needs
way more attention than them just
throwing it into Hogwarts Legacy exactly
yep I'm right there with you
right there with you quidditch is such a
big game that's added to Hogwarts Legacy
might have been too much for the pro for
them to program
don't know if most people's computers
could have handled so much yeah yeah
so much uh
excuse me I think it would have been so
much on the devs really because it's it
just requires so much I mean clearly
they felt the same way like WB the fact
that they're saying we think a full-on
studio needs to dedicate we can dedicate
a whole game to this
what do you guys think here's here's
where we're gonna get in really uh
interesting Waters here interesting
territory
what do you guys think the monetization
is going to be
because I'll tell you guys what I think
it's gonna be
and
and why it has the potential to be a
good thing
this is not sponsored WB has not paid me
for this
I know I'm like singing the Praises
but I promise I
I think it could be but they have to be
very careful with it very careful you
guys already know where I'm going
you you know where I'm going Chris
welcome in going well going well Harry
Potter you I would hope you would try
any Harry Potter game Harry Potter
love that it's a separate game
multiplayer gives you pause yeah see I
feel like there's a lot of people who
are fans of Hogwarts Legacy
see I've seen both sides of it right I I
see all the comments there were so many
of you who were like single players
where I met I want like single players
what I want but then there are also so
many people
commenting and shouting and screaming
multiplayer even in Hogwarts Legacy
people were wanting some sort of
multiplayer mode added even if it wasn't
Quidditch
people were asking for that
man excuse me I cannot like this uh
tonight our beverage of choice is a
Waterloo the carbonated water the black
cherry
oh man and I keep having to Clear My
Throat on this one whoo
but yeah so I I've seen both sides of
the equation when it comes to
multiplayer no multiplayer the reality
is this game has to be multiplayer guys
it has to for any chance of success
it has to be multiplayer that that's
really the only way
now I feel like what most people who are
kind of like yeah and and you know what
here's the other thing I'll say though
if it's not for you it's not for you
like Draco was saying earlier in the
chat like you know I don't know if this
is for me I'm probably going to be
playing Harry Potter magic awake and
more that's totally fine it's completely
different type of game
uh you run into this a lot on YouTube
too like trying to figure out your your
target audience you know Hogwarts Legacy
was one of those games it was a special
game for many reasons but mainly because
it appealed to so many different types
of Gamers because anybody and non-gamers
for that matter
anybody who had ever read the books ever
watched the movies and dreamed of
getting sorted and going to The
Wizarding World you instantly had a
connection with like Oh I wanna I would
want to do that I want to go to Hogwarts
I want to get sorted I want to be I want
to be in the castle you know
but quit is just a little bit different
even even as a book reader
and even when you put yourself in that
world some people are just like it's a
cool side thing but I I wouldn't play
Quidditch if I went to Hogwarts some
people might be thinking so if it's not
for you don't sweat it even if you're a
Wizarding World Fan don't feel like you
have to support the game or or buy the
game
just because you're a Wizarding World
Fan now in terms of the monetization
I think it's going to be free to play
I do guys I think it's going to be free
to play it's just it's a complete guess
I don't know
I I don't have any concrete reasons for
it but I'll go back to a few years ago
when there was remember the whole WB
Discovery the merger all that stuff that
happened
and now this this recent announcement
about the Harry Potter TV show
when all of that went down one of the
other things they said
is WB Games that is is that they wanted
more games as a service
they wanted more games as a service
and that is one of my big reasons for it
also because I think it's just like
I think it's perfectly set up to be a
free-to-play game I really do because of
what we were just talking about there
are so many people who are going to be
like I'm kind of on the fence with this
you know like yes I'm a fan of the
Wizarding World but I'm not really a
sports person right I don't know if I
want to play Quidditch but if it's if
they come out they're like it's free
it's free
free to try free to play they would get
a lot more people on board especially in
the beginning just to try it out I do
that that that is what I'm thinking
Cosmetics oh my gosh yes Cosmetics
custom brooms uniforms absolutely all
all of those things
Luna comic says they must incorporate
those special moves from the original or
have more than one that'll be
interesting to see what they do with uh
I have I have so many questions see I
can already feel us slipping into the
Hogwarts sea streams again to where we
were just
go down these rabbit holes when we have
all these questions man because I for
sure think they're going to have to
change the rules they're going to have
to or I should say tweak the rules maybe
they have like a hardcore mode or
something that's true to the actual book
rules but then they have like a standard
mode
because at the end of the day guys you
you CA you cannot have 150 points for
the snitch and that ending the game that
it just they can't structure it like
that
if they do
gosh you're gonna have so many people
raging like you if you've seen people
you know rage compilations online people
rage quitting games
oh my goodness people are going to be
very competitive in this game trust me
they'll be very competitive
and if you have I mean imagine you have
a game where you're just like your
Chasers you're dominating you know
you're 100 to 50 uh 150 to 20.
and then somebody catches the snitch and
if they actually give them 150 points
and it ends the game
I think there are two different options
for how they can handle it we were
talking about this the other day on our
twitch live stream I think there are two
options there is actually a real world
quidditch you guys didn't know about
this it is a it is a sport that people
play
obviously they're not flying in the air
and so the roles have to be tweaked a
little bit and so the way they do it you
guys can look it up online to find the
exact point total but
um if the team that's winning there's
like a certain time when the snitch is
available
it's not just like open anytime to catch
the snitch there's only a certain
certain times when when they can get it
and if the team that's ahead catches the
snitch
the game is over
if the team that's behind catches the
snitch I want to say it rewards them
like 30 points
and so if if the 30 points would put you
as the winner it doesn't matter who
catches it you win game's over
but if the 30 points would not put you
ahead
it extends the game
so like remember in the book when Victor
Crum caught the snitch but his team lost
and so he basically he
I mean think about that from a gameplay
perspective if that actually happened in
a video game is so problematic for for
how how it will work in a video game
because then I mean what are you doing
as a Seeker you're not going to try and
catch it I guess you could try and like
become a almost become a beater where
you're trying to force their Seeker not
to catch it until your team catches up
but then you could just have games go on
forever right so I kind of like that and
because it still keeps the spirit of the
books and like catching the snitch is
what ends the game
um but but how it works is if so let's
say you're you're down by 40 points and
your team catches the snitch you would
get 30 so then you're down 10 and then
you go into what they call an overtime
period
but still to end the game you have to
catch the snitch now I don't know how it
works if a team's down by a whole lot
and then I guess they could just keep
having overtimes right if if the same
Seeker so if you have like a really good
seeker and they keep catching the snitch
for you that would keep extending the
game so that's one possibility the other
idea that I had is
you could do it like most of our real
real world Sports and and have like
timed periods or quarters halves however
you want to do it
and you could structure it in a way like
the snitch would have to be worth
significantly less
significantly less like maybe 25 or 30.
and once it's caught it's released back
after like five minutes or something I
don't know
and so then at the end you just tally
the total points and so it ends on like
it ends on a Time rather than the
catching of the snitch
but it's so interesting man it's
fascinating there's going to be a lot of
different
ways that they can handle that
um Chris you think there will be
microtransactions yeah I think so too
for sure
I I definitely think that they will have
Micro transactions broom skins
everyone will be in Quidditch team gear
yeah true but they could have like they
could have different styles of the gear
um like kind of like what we see with uh
with Hogwarts Legacy like all the
different house uniforms there's so many
different variations like the way the
stripes and they could have so many I
mean if you're a fan of uh modern sports
a big thing right now is they have like
throwback uniforms so teams have like
their home Jersey they have their away
jersey then they have their throwback
jerseys some teams have a couple of
throwback jerseys then they have like
these alternate helmets that they wear
sometimes
so
oh and like look even I just realized in
the screenshot like the goggles right
there you customize goggles like the
helmet the the stadiums oh my goodness
I really hope they have all the
different stadiums like quidditch World
Cup did Dynamic weather
um of course not talking micro
transactions with weather surely not
don't do that WB do not do that but I
could see them definitely doing it like
stadiums all the Cosmetics that you can
get for the character
brooms for sure brooms for sure brooms
let's see what else do we have I think
it'll it'll play like a battle royale's
Bluff
uh Samantha said I'm not into sports
games but I will buy the game want to
give it a try
uh Chris says that's where I'm at Love
The Wizarding World but probably won't
get this in play yeah and that's fine
you know I think that's fine because
this is a very different I should say
very different but it is a slightly
different target audience
Craig says having someone make a meal
and bring it out to you is a service
games or entertainment
uh Maris if they don't do a free to play
they will have a much lower player base
I agree I agree and even if they do
charge for it
I don't think it'll be a full price game
I think it'll be like a twenty dollar or
thirty dollar and then with micro
microtransactions supplementing things
which
people are going to freak out if that
if that actually happens I I've already
seen it in my YouTube comments about
people already and let's be real I mean
there are reasons that people hate micro
transactions because a lot of times
Publishers and developers the way they
do it is just it's just anti-consumer
and it's it's it's greedy
and it's just it's unfortunate man it is
so I get
the weariness I get the concern however
I'm choosing to Hope as we did with
Hogwarts Legacy I'm choosing to hope
that the game is in the right hands
of the developers here
which is not Avalanche by the way the
developers are not Avalanche what is
their name again
hold on we gotta pull up the
I want to make sure I get the exact name
right but which already man if you
follow these guys on Twitter they have
been so active already
and they really are striking me I'm
getting similar Vibes to how we did with
Avalanche in terms of just how excited
they are to be working on this project
unbroken Studios
unbroken Studios they were tweeting the
other day they had a a little party and
had like I think it was a snitch cookie
or something no cupcakes there they are
I just found them they said if you
followed us for a little while longer
than this week you might have noticed
our Affinity here in the office for
donuts celebrating quidditch Champions
announcement I present to you sticky
snitches
oh man I gotta pull these up over here
for you guys look at this
look at this
sticky snitches I'm just salivating
looking at that picture right there man
so I think the the passion and
excitement is definitely there
it's definitely there now
of course they're working a lot with WB
in terms of the pricing structure and I
think WB will have a big say in terms of
as as publisher you know they're gonna
set up a lot of that
so hopefully man hopefully they do it
right so let's let's think of some games
that have done it right
at least from my perspective I mean
fortnite's got to be the king of this
right hey love it love or hate fortnite
this is this is an amazing thing you
guys you can go and download fortnite
right now without paying anything and
you can play the full game I'm not
talking about save the world I'm talking
fortnite Battle Royale you can play the
full game you can do everything
in that game
and yet they have made so much money off
of Cosmetics what your character wears
emo oh dude emotes how can we forget
that there's a hundred percent gonna be
emotes you guys were talking about in
quidditch World Cup all of the like the
special moves they're gonna be taunts
and emotes a hun oh my gosh I can't
believe I didn't think of that before
a thousand percent there are going to be
taunts and emotes
in this game for sure there you go
there's micro transactions right there
and see what's so funny is like I don't
I don't care about the emotes I don't
think I ever bought an emote in fortnite
I I feel like I is I personally have
spent very little money in fortnite at
all
I think I bought like one of the first
battle passes and the way see here's
what's so great about how fortnite does
it man
you can buy the battle pass which is
like 10 bucks and then if you if as long
as you don't spend that those V bucks
that you get
you get V bucks through the battle pass
that you just paid ten dollars for so
you get a bunch of stuff in the battle
pass and then you get V bucks from that
battle pass as well if you don't spend
anything you have enough to buy the next
battle pass without paying anything else
so it's like you just have this like
infinite as long as you keep doing that
now my son is the exact opposite he's
like he wants all the lay all the all
the skins and I'm just like no no
because they're ridiculously overpriced
in my opinion
but in terms of like the fact that the
game is free and the fact they give you
all that stuff with the battle pass
same thing for Apex Legends
and Apex Legends guys you know how much
I've spent on that game and I've
probably played
I'll have to check my Play Time sometime
on apex Legends but I mean it's at least
I feel like
at least 500 hours in that game I played
a lot of that game back when it first
came out
and that game dropped out of nowhere
free to play you know how much I've
spent on apex
zero dollars zero dollars because I I do
not care
in the slightest
about the different character skins
about the the skins on the weapons I
just don't care I don't care
I ca I shouldn't say I don't care I
don't care enough to spend real world
money on it
and and then again like similar to what
fortnite does you can earn so much by
playing the game that I've been able to
get all the Apex characters just by
playing the game just by playing the
game so I hope
that WB will set up something similar to
where it's not pay to win to wear
anything that you do in the game
anything in terms of the actual gameplay
is not locked behind a paywall like
special modes and all that I don't get
into that like
don't just just don't get into it a free
mobile app game no Lauren no no it's not
a mobile game it is officially for
console and PC they have confirmed that
yes
they have confirmed that
and yeah I think I read your comment
earlier Marist but I totally agree about
that's the great thing about with a
multiplayer game when you go free to
play
is it makes your player base in
multiplayer games to to survive and
thrive they have to have a big player
base
now I could see this one oh here's a
good question if they if it is like a
full price game
I could totally see PlayStation trying
to secure it as a Playstation Plus game
and seeing the success of Hogwarts
Legacy I could equally see Microsoft
being like uh no
we want that on Game Pass
oh dude oh it's gonna be so interesting
but yeah it is it is not a mobile game I
know people saw the art
and initially thought because it looks
very similar to
which one is it
Hogwarts mystery I feel like is the one
that it looks similar to doesn't really
I could see some some connections to
Magic awaken maybe a little bit to
wizards Unite
the snitch could be nerfed to about 50
points yeah Dylan they're gonna have to
do something with the snitch for sure
have to do something to adjust it
yes Lord that's right yeah if you guys
didn't know in that in that real world
version of quidditch the snitch is is a
person who it is actually a person who
dresses up and wearing gold and I think
they have like a flag or something on
them that somebody has to catch
you guys really should look this up like
it's it's
actually I I don't think I've ever even
looked up a video I should look up a
video of a real world quidditch being
played JG is this game going to be good
we have no idea we haven't seen anything
we haven't seen anything in terms of
gameplay so right now it is just a
cautious optimism for me
cautious optimism the studio I would say
is pretty unproven
uh and honestly like they don't have
nearly the experience that Avalanche had
I mean Avalanche had a very long and
lengthy history of
working on
games that were more for kids and so
that's why people were a little bit
skeptical of them but they they
certainly had a big big history of of
working on games
this was just this being Hogwarts Legacy
was just completely different type of
game for them and
by almost every account they absolutely
knocked it out of the park
this team
uh has worked with
other big time developers they worked on
Call of Duty they've worked on God of
War they worked on Batman Arkham and
then what was the other one there was
another big multiplayer title
uh but obviously they've not been the
lead on any of those this it seems like
they are in fact the lead Studio on this
so it's hard to say JG just yet but
there are play tests happening now as we
were touching on a little bit earlier
and it all just depends on if you are in
that play test or not that's why I can't
wait to get my hands I hope I get in at
some point on the play test but
as soon as I do
then it kind of prevents discussions
like this from happening I can't I can't
speculate on things I that I know about
if I if I had played the game so
Samantha thank you so much for being
here have a good one Jacob would be cool
to see the team intros oh intros dude
that's a great idea
that is a great idea
I could see that being a little bit of
like a battle pass type thing too as
well like something that they might
include as a
as a some sort of micro transaction like
different like like you have the
standard one this is their standard
entrance
but then if you they might have
microtransactions for uh special
entrances and stuff
um Mara says I see it being a battle
pass setup like other comp games
fortnite OverWatch Etc yeah that's where
I'm leaning right now
that's where I'm leaning and honestly
like if done correctly I don't hate it I
don't hate it at all and I feel like the
the reaction online if that's the way it
goes
again I don't even know if it'll be the
majority but I feel like there's going
to be a lot of people being loud and
complaining this is what I feel like
that's what I feel how long are we
streaming uh Harry Potter uh let's see
this is our almost our last segment this
is topic of the week then we're gonna
get into viewer questions and then we'll
have the wrap up segment after that
I know those cupcakes look so good they
look so good
so Chris okay Chris this might be this
might be a good uh little insight for
for uh WB to hear if they if they happen
to catch any of this stream so Chris
said if it's free to play I'll for sure
play but if it costs money I'm not in
quidditch enough to pay
I don't feel like uh that's an uncommon
thing Chris I feel like there will be a
lot of people in that same boat as you
as being like I'm a fan of the Wizarding
World but I'm not really a sports fan
and this game it's about a sport even
though it's a Wizarding squirrel spoiled
sport I'm not sure if I'll like it by
making it free to play
it's just it lowers that barrier to
entry right and also you know what else
free to play says it says that you're
confident in the game
it does it says that you're you're
confident that people are gonna have fun
with the game
to where they will want to spend money
on the cosmetics and keep coming back
for all that kind of stuff so
uh like I said I'm I'm cautiously
optimistic by the way how how insane was
this just out of nowhere as an
announcement right just out of nowhere I
mean nobody was
it was not on my radar at all
because uh my buddy expecto go and I and
wizard PhD we have talked about this
stuff like and said we would love to see
this in the future you know but never in
a million years did I think it was going
to be announced the year
that Hogwarts Legacy released
and also the year that fingers crossed
magic awaken finally releases over here
oh and Lauren seeing your comment about
the Nimbus and the Firebolt
that I know I'm not answering your
question right here I'll get back to
your question but that made me think of
here's another thing why people wouldn't
want it set in the time of Hogwarts
Legacy those brooms are slower they're
not as agile they're not as nimble
this game I think they chose the Harry
Potter name for a lot of different
reasons
but one thing I was thinking about
because of the fact that they're calling
it Harry Potter Quidditch Champions they
could have very easily just called this
quidditch Champions Wizarding World
quidditch Champions Hogwarts quidditch
Champions quidditch World Cup champion I
I don't know there's a lot of different
names but they chose Harry Potter
quidditch Champions so I don't think
there's gonna be like a big story line
or anything to this game but that does
beg the question of of like is Harry
gonna be in the game like
is it actually set at the time he's at
school
are we gonna actually be able to play oh
my gosh I just thought of something
crazy dude what if what if they have
where you can play these like iconic
matches from the series
from each year of of Harry's Hogwarts
schooling
dude like I've seen that done in Madden
and NBA 2K they've done things like that
before where they'll have it set up to
where you can play this iconic game from
the history of sports so it could be
like a specific Super Bowl or a specific
NBA championship that was a really big
pivotal game
even to where you have to do specific
tasks in the game
oh man also we should also point out
guys in the FAQ they also mention other
flying games
so I think there's going to be some
extracurriculars here it's not just
going to be
quidditch I think we could see some
little like training mini games and
things to help you learn the ropes of
the game learn how to fly
all those types of things
but yeah the fact that they're setting
it in modern times means that you're
going to have the best brooms
that was thank you Lauren can you get me
back on track there that is what when I
saw that comment from you that's what
made me think of that in the first place
is because the Hogwarts Legacy devs they
specifically talked about they had to
consider look these are older brooms
this is not a fireball this is not a
nimbus we can't have this being just a
ridiculously fast agile Nimble perfect
turn broom
like Harry and and the others have in in
the book series
this game by setting it by calling it
Harry Potter Quidditch champions
I think we're gonna have access to those
faster brooms oh dude oh man see here I
go here I go the idea is they're just
they're just spilling out of me now
they're pouring out of me they could
even have different eras of quidditch
like imagine if you get to play
Quidditch like on the on the original
hoops
like uh I ca I'm I'm not red quidditch
to the ages in a while but I know they
didn't start with the exact Hoops like
they have you can actually see some of
the early
attempts at getting quidditch going in
Hogwarts Legacy with the uh as you fly
around the world
they could do things like that like
different eras of quidditch like how it
changes Through The Years there you go
quidditch Through the Ages
different Stadium I know Draco I hope we
get to see different stadiums I feel
like that's a given different stadiums
weather day night all those types of
things for sure
oh man imagine if they did different
schools like if we could see different
schools
uh quidditch pitch
that would be insane okay back to
Lauren's comment though now you might
have to pay extra for special brooms
yeah I I agree I think so would I pay
for a fire bolt or a classic Nimbus ooh
that's tough I'd have to look at the
stats but see
oh and that takes us down another Rabbit
Hole though right because those brooms
should have stats on them
so hopefully they don't go that way
because that would almost feel like a
pay to win I think it would have to be
Cosmetics instead so like painting your
broom
getting a different I don't know broom
handle
changing up I I don't know I don't know
a ribbon or something on the Broom
cosmetic to make the snitch look like a
snidget oh my goodness Craig
now that you said that if that doesn't
happen if there is not a mode in this
game with a snidget I'm gonna be so
disappointed
be so disappointed
oh
see imagine if they had like where you
how many times have I said imagine
sheesh guys this is just how it goes
whenever we whenever I get excited about
something the idea is they just start
flowing man they start flowing imagine
if you could play
quidditch in these different eras so
you're playing in the original just like
they're just starting out what was the
guy's name kennel worthy wisp oh no
that's the name of the guy that wrote
the book
oh what was the name of the dude who
started Quidditch
I can't remember his name
oh somebody in the chat will remember
one of you guys will remember but
and then if you go back that far you got
to have the golden snidget you have to
you have to have the golden snidget
oh my goodness what a great idea pool
cue welcome in thank you for being here
uh Draco said different schools will be
sweet and I agree quidditch at night yes
at night would be so good
so good all right guys before we move on
any final thoughts here on our topic of
the week on
Harry Potter Quidditch Champions I'm
excited for it man you guys already know
where to keep it tuned if you're not yet
subscribed here to our YouTube channel
make sure you subscribe we're going to
be covering this game
as extensively as we did Hogwarts Legacy
and what's really exciting about this
one I know some of you weren't too
thrilled with the idea of multiplayer
stuff but guys we can start doing
community nights playing playing this
game together
and if magic awakened ever comes out we
can do the same thing there too that is
one of the reasons I'm so excited about
this because the community that we've
built here if you guys are catching this
later also know that we have a Discord
that you can join as well
so I can see the Discord and stuff like
that really picking up when this game
actually comes out because all of us can
then join up together and play so that's
going to be a lot of fun
Lauren might play against Victor Chrome
there you go see now you got the ideas
are flowing for you guys too according
to Pottermore stories uh he was still
playing in the World Cup in 2014. yes
see now that they need iconic players
that we can go against
oh that is earlier I said there are two
things confirmed the other big thing
confirmed is we will be able to create
our own character
we will create our own character so
there will be a character creator so I
don't think we're going to be playing as
other
although I mean they could have special
modes
they could definitely play special modes
oh Draco yeah I will for sure play Harry
Potter magic awakened when it finally
comes out over here absolutely I thought
about even trying uh because I know
there were ways to do it even if you
don't live in those areas but none of
the progress carries over so I'm just
like come on bring me the final game
bring me the final game I don't want to
do all this work and then none of it
carry over
all right so we are going to shift into
our final segment viewer questions now
this does not have it can be about
quitted Champions but this can be about
any gaming topic Wizarding World topic
whatever you guys would like to talk
about you could post it in the chat now
but first I'm going to check and see if
we had any questions submitted
through the little chat box so there's a
box where you guys could have submitted
questions
let's see if we have any here
uh let's see we've got one from Ken do
you think they will have preset
fictional players dude
Ken submitted this question forever ago
but that's that is so timely that is
exactly what we were just talking about
so the full question from Ken here guys
do you think they will have preset
fictional players with different stats
like OverWatch Etc to choose in the
Quidditch game or will the players all
have the same stats and customize their
look
Ken that is such a good question I
played a ton of sports games as a kid
too
and I I can't believe I never thought of
that question
because that is
yeah so like when you create your
character
will you pick from like a preset or will
all the all the characters start at at
zero and then you have to do certain
activities because like my biggest
reference point is Madden I played a lot
of Madden and so obviously if you play a
real world team they're already gonna
have their own stats and attributes
height weight how fast they are whether
they can catch all those types of things
you know
but when you create your own character
in a game like Madden you customize
everything
that is such a good question so
in a game like quidditch I don't know
that height and weight I don't know that
all that will matter
although maybe maybe like weight will
matter for oh dude like strength I could
see strength being an important stat
like if you're a beater then you're
really gonna need a high strength stat
if you're primarily a Seeker you're
going to need speed Chaser you're gonna
need speed but you're also gonna need to
like Bob and weave but then you also
need like a decent amount of strength as
well for the Chaser because you have to
be throwing the quaffle
whereas the keeper oh dude
so many
I can't believe I never considered that
question
that is that is a a great question
though Ken one that I don't know the
answer to and can't wait until we get
the answer
uh Dylan submitted a question have you
ever played Dragon Age I have never
hold on I take that back I bought
I'm pretty sure it was Inquisition
Dragon Age Inquisition there was a time
when it went on sale in the PlayStation
Store for I don't know something like
five bucks and I was like okay I've
always heard a plate that this is a good
game I'm I'm buying this
even if I'm not going to play it right
away and you guys have already heard me
talk about my backlog enough
I I've never played it I've never gotten
around to playing it
I'm pretty sure though Dylan that I
would enjoy it if I ever did play it I
am pretty sure of that
but no I've never other than just like
that initial I played like the very
little beginning sequence of Inquisition
and that's it
uh Fallen didn't have a question that
had a comment Metroid is so underrated
Fallen I'm with you
I'm with you Metroid needs more love
although the the Metroid Prime remaster
actually sold really really well really
really well last time I checked I
haven't looked at updated numbers or
anything but
and then a question from Harry Potter
101 do you think WB Games will keep
making
Harry Potter games for the next few
Generations
I think so dude I think so
I mean I think we're we're seeing the
start of that right now
and with them doubling down on the
Wizarding World as a Harry Potter's a
franchise I mean
the the CEO David zaslav I think is his
name I'm not sure if I'm pronouncing it
correctly but he has talked about how
they want to double down on and this is
not just WB Games this is WB as a whole
they want to double down on like big IP
known quantities things that they know
will do well and
Avalanche with Hogwarts Legacy has has
set the standard you know I think
they're certainly going to be doing
another game
actually I talked about this in today's
YouTube video If you guys haven't seen
today's video not even WB expected this
is the title
Hogwarts Legacy has made over 850
million
million dollars and that was in like the
first couple weeks or something we have
we don't have updated numbers
the only thing we heard is that it sold
over 12 million it sold over 12 million
copies
and that has been a few weeks old it's
also coming out on last gen next week
so clearly they have seen that the
market is there Harry Potter clearly
they have seen the market is there for
you my friend it is there for you and
then this quidditch Champions
announcement
I I think so I think so I I think
the next big one that I want to see and
this one I think could be a ways off
because unless unless they're gonna drop
another totally out of left field
announcement on us like we got with
quidditch Champions the next one that
they need to do is an MMO
an MMO massively multiplayer online I'm
not saying Avalanche I think Avalanche
needs to do another Hogwarts Legacy too
because I think
as much as they knocked it out of the
park with this one being able to take
everything they've done all the lessons
they've learned from that game and put
it into a sequel
it would it would absolutely
it would absolutely blow Hogwarts Legacy
out of the water I firmly believe that
because that I believe in that team and
I think everybody should believe in that
team now but but seeing what all they
did
with being totally new to that type of
genre oh yeah I mean I'd love to see to
back to the original question I'd love
to see where they have just like a
a new Wizarding World game or two every
year every year coming out and I think
it's big enough for that I do
I do I think there is so much in The
Wizarding World
that they could do
the key is to make it to be able to
succeed outside of like Hogwarts I've
talked about this a lot and with uh
expecto go and some other
Hogwarts Legacy creators it's like once
you start taking things out of Hogwarts
we the die hards would support it like
if you give me an over morning game if
you give me a wagadu game if you give me
anything in the Wizarding World I'm
there I'm gonna play it
but those would not have that same Mass
Appeal
that Hogwarts does
however over time over time I really
feel like they could build something
truly special in terms of just having
this this stable of of Wizarding World
Games to where
to where it's covering all the genres
man to where you've got like action
games to where you've got the RPG the
action RPG like Hogwarts Legacy to where
you've got the sports game the the free
to play which is we're guessing on that
part with quidditch champions
then you need to come out with an MMO
man
bring out the MMO
that would be incredible so maybe maybe
Harry Potter your question maybe this is
just an I hope so
but I also feel pretty confident that
they will I mean and it's gonna depend
on too like if quidditch Champions isn't
a good game if it doesn't do well then
they'll pull the plug I mean we've seen
them pull the plug like if you if you
look at Wizards Unite
Unfortunately they had to pull the plug
on that way earlier than I think a lot
of people I know there was a very
dedicated and loyal audience for that
game but ultimately they just decided it
wasn't big enough to keep doing so
they've shown that they'll experiment
excuse me they've shown they'll
experiment they've also shown that
they'll pull the plug if they have to
but the encouraging thing is like
they're trying new things man they're
they're continuing to try to iterate
within the Wizarding World for video
games which is a great thing if you're a
fan of the Wizarding World
and a fan of video games Hello I think
you probably are if you're here right
now
it's it's a great time man and and I
really
a lot of us said when Hogwarts Legacy
hit and it did what it did
a lot of us said this is the beginning
of a new era and I'm standing by that I
really do think it's a new era of of The
Wizarding World in terms of a
of video games
so hopefully
hopefully quidditch Champions will carry
the torch Jenna Roland welcome in thank
you so much Jenna for being here uh
let's see I saw a question about
let's see where did it go I saw a DLC oh
hold on before the DLC question though
somebody said if you could design your
own game oh my goodness Mia this is good
if you could design your own game what
genre would it be and what would the
story be about
oh my goodness Mia that that is a deep
a deep and difficult question
okay so some of my favorite games of all
time the last of us is my favorite game
ever made
but I also really love games like Elden
ring
and the from software games so I think
it would be it would be something with
as incredible of a story
as The Last of Us
and something with the gameplay of
it doesn't have to be exactly like Eldon
ring but but something with that kind of
core
gameplay Loop so I think it would be an
action RPG
I think it would be open world
oh man it might be it might be a
Wizarding World game
it might be
but I I have such a hard time like
seeing in my head how would they get a
Wizarding World game to work with we saw
in Hogwarts Legacy like they really
struggled with like having rewarding
loot
it just wasn't rewarding to find you
know the red sweater that's five levels
below what you have
when you go journey into the cave and
solve this big puzzle
but see Elder ring has an advantage it's
like okay one cave you can find an ax
the next cave you find this super
powerful magical staff
the next cave you find this enormous
great sword then you find a dagger for
beating this boss it's like
but when you're in the Wizarding World
there's it's like you got your wand and
that everything has to in terms of the
combat it all has to tie back to the
wand so I don't
oh I don't know that's such a good
question though
such a good question
now you got me just like
I'm just dreaming big here just dreaming
big
uh Draco do you think there might be a
Harry Potter MMO being made seeing how
well hog looks like he did uh I mean I'm
gonna say yes like I I'm not saying like
that it's currently in development but
in terms of all the big fan requests
that I've seen so covering Hogwarts
Legacy like I did for geez two and a
half three years I don't even know what
it's been at this point
I feel like they hit the nail on the
head with the I feel like the biggest
request was open world
story focused action RPG I I do feel
like that was the biggest one
the next thing I feel like was MMO
MMO was what I got I saw that comment so
many times of like I wish it was an MMO
I wish it was an MMO this is not an MMO
I can't believe it's not an MMO
and I mean one thing I could say about
WB and the people at Avalanche it's like
they they definitely listen to the
community they do I think we've seen
that on a number of occasions now
as as we've seen with quidditch which
the thing that blows my mind about
quiddish the fact that it's been in
development for three years that shows
they they like had a little bit of
foresight there to know that
okay people are really going to want to
quit each game
they will really want a Quidditch game
next question what DLC do I think
Hogwarts Legacy will get okay so if like
my prediction I think we'll get like a
story DLC
that is gonna be like a collection of
maybe some new missions
so like I don't know
three to five new sort of like mini side
quests and then one big story mission
that will be like multiple steps
now the thing that I can't figure out
Chris if that holds true I can't figure
out how it will work for the time frame
of the game like does it just
I mean I guess technically we the way
the game ends it's like the school year
is still happening even though we like
see the ow Bells
so you kind of have to suspend your
disbelief a little bit there it's like
okay really they should be going home at
this point
so yeah or maybe they like if they went
really crazy I mean it could do
something like a a have it set in the
summer
but then like if the Castle's empty how
would that work
so yeah I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
keep it simple and say story DLC with
some additional uh minor missions and
then lots of Cosmetics I think there'll
be lots more cosmetics in the DLC
probably another battle arena
as well because we've seen we've seen
like the dark arts battle arenas oh and
then you know what another
um
I don't think I've ever said this one
but another vivarium I could see like an
additional vivarium and maybe some new
magical creatures
I'm not saying all this in one DLC I'm
just saying like DLC I feel like these
are kind of like the most likely
possibilities in terms of DLC
and then hopefully simple things well
this wouldn't really be DLC though would
it like because I'm still thinking
and wanting things like New Game Plus
things like Photo mode which I don't
consider those like DLC to me DLC is
like a substantial new piece of content
that's either like a new mode or some
big new chunk of the story I think so
um
they could have done special one
capabilities learning unique spells per
area completed
yeah that would have been an interesting
zodiac like if they tied the learning of
spells to
you know what Zodiac okay
at first I was thinking no but the more
the more I think about it
I could maybe see that working yeah you
still have to learn kind of like the
core Spells at the school
but then what if they had all these like
additional supplemental spells that
aren't necessary
they're not necessary to beat the game
but if you go on this specific Quest and
and do this or find this cave or
something you know
you might learn
aquamenti but then they would have to
make like there would have to be moments
where augmenti would be useful oh did I
say new spells new spells would be
awesome in a DLC
new spells would be incredible
I'd love to see that yeah I think so
Draco like Photo mode I consider that
more like a patch thing like an update
not like a DLC
all right let's see if we had any more
people uh submit questions yes we did we
have a couple more
Harry Potter uh kind of more of a
suggestion here I think they should make
a game about Fantastic Beasts because of
how fun it was to run around in Hogwarts
like see Catching animals yeah that I
could see that succeeding and then uh
xavin sarkeesian well Harry Potter
characters be in this game or only our
own created characters dude I have the
same question we were talking about that
earlier
I don't know why that it didn't hit me
earlier I mean the fact that they're
calling it Harry Potter Quidditch
champions
okay so let's break that into two parts
zaven we know for sure we're gonna
create our character we know that for
sure
but then they're calling it Harry Potter
Quidditch Champions now so far Harry
Potter as a character we've not seen him
in any of the promotional materials he's
not appeared in anything
but the fact that his name is in the
title
I'm gonna say yes we don't know for sure
though I'm just I'm just that's my
prediction right now
that is my prediction
all right let's see I saw I know I saw
another question here
and actually let's go ahead and end our
q a you guys can just post it in the
main
you could just post it in the main chat
box there and we'll see it
uh Lauren said the problem with Hogwarts
legacies you never know what your
character's backstory is former squib do
you have a family muggle board are you
an orphan or now living and now living
in Hogwarts yeah yeah I I agree Lauren I
agree I feel like we needed a little bit
more with the story I mean I think what
they were going for there
I think clearly what they were trying to
do is like they wanted it to be a bit of
a blank slate to where like you are
becoming your character so you can like
make up the backstory for your character
because it's you know creating you're
creating your character for Hogwarts but
then if you're gonna go that route like
at least let us do the match if they'd
had like a series of questions at the
beginning of the game
to where you can kind of like if you're
gonna let us make it up like let us
actually make it up in the game give us
a series of questions where we can kind
of like build this character backstory
and it could be like preset you know
like give you like three options
oh dude that would have been I know a
lot of people wanted to do blood status
like imagine if at the beginning of the
game
after you create your character it was
like okay choose your blood status
muggleborn pure blood half blood
if it was like are you um
oh man they yeah they could they could
have had a lot of questions though just
like to gauge your backstory
and then based on those because they're
presets based on how you answer them
characters could have then referenced it
in the game that would have been so cool
foreign
I agree
will there be weather conditions in this
game I assume you're talking about for
Quidditch
we don't know for sure but I think so
yeah I I think so
see those are the types of things that
because they're doing a full-fledged
dedicated game for this
I'm way more on the side of yes than if
it was like Hey guys Hogwarts like as
he's coming or uh quidditch is coming to
Hogwarts Legacy like if they'd done
something like that
then I would really be tempering
people's expectations of like guys there
it's just going to be attacked on mode
there's not going to be a lot to it but
the fact that it is its own Standalone
game
yeah I I totally think that we're gonna
see
see Dynamic weather and also like
night games oh man that'd be awesome to
see night games different stadiums
yeah I think for sure we're gonna get
those things the chill 808 welcome in
dude thank you for being here
uh Chris would have been cool but we
would have never gotten Legacy if they
did that Hogwarts Legacy coming 24 oh I
know right if they
kept adding more and more and more
I don't think we know about engine yet
uh zaven guys in the chat was asking I
wonder if it's using Unreal Engine 5 we
do not know uh what do you guys think
about the art style I'm okay with it I
know a lot of I feel like
I feel like it's about 70 30.
of people not really digging the art
style
I'm okay with it though I I think I'm
fine with it being that style to kind of
differentiate it
from Hogwarts Legacy I'm totally fine
with that hey and Patrick with the two
months as well
you've been a member way longer than two
months because you've you've got the
you've got the oh wait I guess the
purple one is for two months Patrick
for some reason I thought the purple one
was for longer
maybe that's two months in a row
either way Patrick thank you so much for
being a member and all the continued
support
appreciate it my friend guys if you
didn't know you can uh become a channel
member here on our YouTube It's called
joining it's a little bit different than
the terminology on other
other streaming platforms so whenever
you join you will get a special Discord
role you also get access to the emotes
whenever we're doing the live stream
here
hey and just On Cue our buddy Patrick
gifting out
five memberships guys if you got one of
those gifted memberships there make sure
you thank Patrick
thank you so much
all the love and support dude Patrick
always showing support and guys if
you're listening to this in audio form
audio form because I think I think I'm
gonna release this as a podcast as well
it might take me some time to get it all
set up but YouTube has actually added a
new podcast feature so I'm gonna tag
this as a podcast and for those of you
who weren't here at the beginning you
could go back and watch the VOD we
really structured this and set it up in
a different way that we've done our
streams before we actually had different
segments and everything tonight uh so I
had a lot of fun man we started off with
more just like news that we shifted into
a topic of the week and then we get into
everybody's favorite part is when viewer
questions viewer interaction
all these types of things
so I think it's been a a very good first
attempt and we'll tweak as we go if you
guys have any feedback be sure to uh let
me know in the comments on this YouTube
video you could also hit me up on
Twitter as well or let us know in the
Discord any of those will work
I think we've learned that Graphics are
not everything yeah so I asked you guys
about the the art style this is from uh
xavin here the games from our childhood
had terrible Graphics but we're so fun
I'm sure this game will be outstanding
even with these Graphics see the thing
about this style is it's like okay if it
runs better because sports games man
it's got to be a rock solid smooth frame
rate
that's the big thing for me make make it
a smooth frame rate we don't want any
dips
we do not want dips or anything like
that
and Lauren makes another great point
there like it's so early we we saw just
a very short clip and only a few
screenshots so until we can start seeing
other characters what everyone else
looks like what different uniforms look
like what the different stadiums look
like the weather how the game runs
all these types of things
I think are gonna really you know
will help people decide a lot more how
they feel about the art style
oh I didn't see that first part Lauren
how you said you don't like the art but
it is very early yeah absolutely it is
indeed early
Patrick your all-time favorite game is
the original Metroid really
I am surprised by that I did not know
that about you I love the I love Metroid
though
I wouldn't the original wouldn't be at
the top of my list though I think I'd
have to go Metroid Prime and then Super
Metroid
if I had to actually rank them
oh man all right guys for our final
segment oh man this is the one I forgot
to do
see I had I had slides and everything
this is not a real comment
from our YouTube channel
but I will go and pull one
um I thought this would be a fun little
way to end the stream to where I go and
highlight
a new comment each week from one of you
guys on one of our videos because you
guys are always just uh actually I
already know I already know the one
I know the one and it only feels right
to do this one first
it really only feels right to do this
one first because they are almost always
first on our videos shout out to Rossi
on YouTube the quote the comment of the
week is first f-i-r-s-d
Rossi
always I I am like in awe
of Rossi and how quickly
he is able to post when when we post a
new video it is actually insane it's
insane and he is so consistent with it
so consistent there was a time when he
he missed like I didn't see him
commenting on any of the videos and then
then he commented on another another one
apologizing because saying he had been
busy with school I'm like Rossi it's
okay
trust me it is okay so big shout out to
Rossi really appreciate the support and
uh all the comments that you guys leave
on the video so yeah I think this will
be a fun fun little highlight each week
uh to know just so you guys know I do
read the comments man I do read the
comments
and
I it really is hard you know I people
always I'm gonna take this off because
people are going to be like what the
heck creativity what is this did
somebody
it was that actually somebody's quote no
no it wasn't somebody's quilt but
in and I didn't realize this until being
a Creator and having these videos with
with these comments on them but it's
just like
it is so true that idea of how you can
get 99 positive comments I mean 99
people 99 people alone commenting on a
video is incredible like that's
incredible
and then you just get that one you just
you get that one and it may not even be
anything that bad or that mean but you
just get that one
and it's just like oh
and that's the one you think about
so I am I am actively trying to change
that mentality so I think this
highlighting a new comment each week my
favorite comment of the week I think
will be a good way to help me focus on
the positive
Mrs raconteur guys she's she's reading a
lot more comments you guys better watch
out I had I had to hold her back the
other day
I know Nico moderator says I'm too nice
on some of these comments we a lot of
these people we just ban you know if
it's if it's too bad we just ban them
but if it's just a genuine like
disagreement that's fine if it's a
genuine critique that's fine
but then the outright trolls like oh man
you're getting banned yeah you're gone
uh Nico Nico might like the way Mrs
raconteur would handle it a little bit
better I was having to hold her back the
other day oh she she told me a comment
she saw and I was like oh that's that's
actually not even that bad that's
I didn't I didn't even really think
twice about that one
so
it was uh no I'm not gonna say the
comment it really wasn't anything too
bad but she was like this comment makes
my blood
like okay you honey it's okay you just
you just you just you leave your comment
give it a thumbs up and you don't that's
it you can just go at that point you
don't have to read all the comments it's
fine but you guys better watch out
that's all I'm saying Christy with the
seven months uh seven months of
Awesomeness thank you so much Christy
appreciate that blue moon you would have
laughed saying that quota on this I know
I thought I was so prepared for the
stream I thought I had all the slides
updated
that's the one I forgot it would have
been funny though to just have uh
Rossi's uh first up there as the quote
but we will try to get to it next week
see now I've got the template in place
that's part of the reason I wanted to
get all this lined up so next week we'll
just be able to go right in and guys I
know some of you kind of jumped in here
toward the end
if you guys jumped in toward the end
let me know in the comments replay Squad
when you go back and watch this let me
know in the comments how you guys feel
about the beginning because uh I
actually think it's going to be much
more enjoyable watching it as a replay
the way we structured the stream tonight
then the way we usually do first of all
there was no countdown we just go
straight into it
and we have kind of a little bit of a
beginning where we do the intro shout
out to people in the chat cover some of
the top gaming stories of the week
talk about what's coming out this week
what I've been playing did we get into
our topic of the week and that's when we
really started to dive into the meat of
the discussion
uh Dandy retro was there any part of you
that was bored with the Hogwarts game I
lost major steam halfway through the
game could finish no no not at all I
definitely uh definitely I mean after I
beat the game and did the 100 then as I
was going for that 100 there were
certainly things that I was kind of like
uh it's kind of dragging
but no I thought the for me the pacing
was really good because except actually
I thought the beginning
I wanted to get more powerful
quicker and also get access to the broom
quicker but I feel like once you unlock
talents and once you unlock the broom
it's just like
Full Speed Ahead from there
Full Speed Ahead at least for me at
least for me it was
can't please everyone exactly Draco like
that's I have to remind myself of that
like
because me like there are so many I
watch so many YouTube videos and enjoy a
lot of them and I never comment
I never comment so the fact that anybody
would stop at all to leave a positive
comment like that alone
like that should totally brighten my day
and it does it does but then you see
like the one
and it's so hard like I feel like
everybody it's just it's just human
nature like our brains just just work
this way right like
if you get if you get 99 out of 100 on a
test it's like wait so wait what did I
miss which one did I miss at least it
was for me I don't know
um but yeah so I'm maybe doing this will
uh help me kind of reframe that a little
bit
uh let's see the chill says are you into
play quiddish no dude I wish
if I was I couldn't say but if I was in
we definitely could not have had the
conversations we had on tonight's show
either we absolutely could not have
because for people who get into the play
test there is an NDA
a non-disclosure agreement
so some of you in the chat right now
though you could be watching he could be
playing
and we would never know
we would never know you guys can send me
a DM though don't worry
I'm kidding I don't want you guys to get
in trouble don't don't get WB mad at you
um
yeah no problem Dandy appreciate you
being here and hanging out
yeah I love the world they built for
sure we did a uh a big stream over on
expecto go
and a lot of us had some critiques for
the story some of the side stories were
probably better than the main story
um but yeah I I mean if forced to put a
score on it I give Hogwarts Legacy a
nine out of ten it's it's been one of my
favorite gaming experiences ever
um but with with some definite areas for
improvement for sure and in a sequel
like we to be clear I think they knocked
it out of the park for Hogwarts Legacy
but
if you give WB or if excuse me if you
give Avalanche the time to do a sequel
building off everything they know
that home run is going to go to a grand
slam I really believe that I really do
believe that
so guys I think that is gonna do it for
tonight I appreciate you all being here
for this week's edition of retro rack
into our live let me know what you guys
think of the new format I really do want
to hear from you I really do want to
hear from you especially channel members
uh and uh podcast listeners as well
because we are hoping to get this up and
posted as a podcast which uh definitely
want to hear from you guys too to see
how this listens as a podcast
I tried to structure it in a way that
you don't have to always see the visuals
but then if you if you do want to see
them you can always come to YouTube and
check them out
appreciate everybody being here uh keep
it tuned to our twitch streams for the
rest of the week because I am planning
to do some streams over there whoops
didn't mean to do that I am planning to
do some streams over there and also if
you guys are not yet following the let's
play Channel and you're into Let's Plays
make sure you go follow the let's play
Channel we're we're almost to 500
subscribers
we just need to double that up get to a
thousand and we'll be golden man we'll
be golden
but thank you guys so much for the
support man all the people that continue
to show up here to these live streams
it really doesn't mean a lot so I think
we're going to keep these on Tuesdays
the time May fluctuate and change based
on what's going on with the family but
right now every Tuesday at 9 00 pm
eastern time you can check us out at
retro reckon Tour live we are also on
Twitter at retro wrecking tour we are on
Twitch at retro wrecking tour we do have
a Discord as well and then of course our
main channel right here youtube.com
retro wrecking tour chat everybody that
was hanging out appreciate you all so
much for being here thank you all so
much for watching and I will talk to you
again soon